قدم رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران
خان ردا مكتوبا الى هيئه المحاسبه الوطنيه
بدلا من المثول امامها للاستماع لشهادته
حول القضيه المعروفه بجامعه القادر قال
خان انه لم يكن قادرا على المثول امامه
مقر الهيئه بسبب انشغاله في التقدم للحصول
على كفالات في عدد من القضايا التي
يواجهها امام محاكمه مدينه لاهور حيث يقيم
واضاف خان ان جميع الادعاءات التي قدمتها
لهيئه في اشعار الاستدعاء المتمثله في
الكسب غير المشروع كانت كاذبه وملفقه
وتستند الى سوء فهم متعمد للقانون وهذا
الدوافع سياسيه على حد وصفه
كما ظهرت لقطات بثها ناشطون اليوم انتشار
عشرات من افراد الشرطه في محيط منزل عمران
خان في اقليم البنجه
[موسيقى]
انضم الينا من اسلام اباد مراسله الجزيره
سميره النمر يا سمير يرحب بك اذا المزيد
معك حول اسباب عدم نثول اخان امام هيئه
المحاسبه الوطنيه وهل من تداعيات متوقعه
لهذه الخطوه
نعم سفيان كان من المفترض ان يصل رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان الى هنا في
العاصمه اسلام اباد حيث مركز هيئه
المحاسبه الوطنيه في للمثول امام الهيئه
برفقه زوجته في القضيه المعروفه بالجامعه
القادر كان هناك
انتشار كثيف للشرطه في محيط الهيئه تحسبا
لوصول عمران خان لكنه اعتذر في النهايه
وقدم ردا مكتوبا عبر محاميه قال انه منشغل
في الحصول على كفالات في القضايا المرفوعه
ضده في مدينه لاهور حيث يقيم هناك سفيان
اكثر من 100 قضيه مرفوعه ضد خان بحسبه
بحسب ما يقوله خان دائما مرفوعه ضده في
عدد من المحاكم ولم يتمكن حتى هذه اللحظه
من تجاوز كل هذه القضايا والحضور
هناك ربما خلال الاسبوع الكامل هناك قضايا
مرفوعه ضده في عدد دائما المحاكم في جهه
من جانب اخر لا تزال قوات الشرطه في اقليم
الانجاب في مدينه لاهورد تحديدا تقوم
بالانتشار خلف في منزل عمران خان بعد ان
امهلته منذ يوم امس بتسليم ما قالت انهم
انه وجود 30 الى 40 ارهابيا في داخل منزله
وهو ما نفاه عمران خان في كلمه سجلها يوم
امس وقال انه لا يوجد اي ارهابي داخل
المنزل واذا كانت الشرطه والسلطات تريد ان
تدخل الى المنزل فلتاتي بمذكره تفتيش
قضائي وان لا تقتحمه عبر هجوم ودع وسائل
الاعلام الى الوصول الى المنزل للتاكد من
ذلك كانت هذه المهله قد انتهت في الساعه
الثانيه ظهرا بالتوقيت المحلي لكن حتى هذه
اللحظات لم تقم الشرطه باقتحام المنزل
شكرا لك سميره من السماء